push that resign button
yes that is one of the most difficult
things in chess and i think
so giri's still thinking but duda he's
shown to giri that he knows he's about
to win
that is so instructed by our christopher
he's such a polite guy of course but
just
okay you're done mate
come on
let's not waste any more time that's
what you're just saying
but gary that's he's still doing the
right thing he's still playing on
there's no pressure to resign
modern etiquette you just play on
forever if you want and now he's trying
to give up his knight
he's trying to play for one last trick
maybe i don't see it if white just
captures the knight as he has done he's
hoping for a stalemate but that's not
going to happen no okay there we go the
rooks have come off the board it's not
stalemate because black's king does have
one safe square to go to and giri
he apologizes for playing on so long and
there we go a result do the wins and
they're talking to each other young
christoph judah is the winner of this
game